I just want to give a little background
on on cavalcade because I think for many
people it occupies a very special place
in cowards work for I think most of us
now who look at his work we tend to
think of him being more about
drawing-room comedy and I think
something like cavalcade seems to come
out of left field in his career but in
fact as his career was unfolding it made
a lot of sense and it figured in with a
lot of what he was already doing and as
he'd been developing in the theater up
to that time he was absolutely at the
height of his fame he had done of just
the year before private lives one of his
all-time greatest plays one of his
legendary partnerships with Gertrude
Lawrence which really defined him but he
really wanted to test himself on a
massive scale and he was playing with
all kinds of wild ideas of things he
could do and you know for those of you
who are Downton Abbey fans this story is
nothing new this was he was this was the
original upstairs downstairs in fact of
focusing on these two upper class and
working class families over the course
of 30 years and British history that
everybody knew at that time but what had
prepared him for doing something on this
scale was his work in reviews which a
lot of people forget about because he
was also staging his work as well as
usually writing the songs and and the
book and the sketches for the reviews
and a lot of his work up in that that
time had been very heavily influenced as
many people's was by the German
expressionist movement and particularly
what had happened in cinema up to that
time at a lot of it was really inspired
by that so you know well a lot of the
reviews were about having a great time
and song-and-dance numbers in comedy
some of the numbers were very dark and
often surrealistic in in how they were
staged but cavalcade was something else
again and when he finally started to
work on it they had to actually set an
opening date before he had actually
written the play because he realized he
needed the most advanced biggest stage
in London and originally he'd wanted the
Coliseum which he couldn't get so they
settled on the Drury Lane which was
massive in which had a turntable that
they could use and he knew that they
could perform all the scene changes that
would be required covering this massive
story the cast and crew of cavalcade
numbered 400
people gives you a clue as to why the
show can't be revived today something
that was fascinating and that's really
picked up on in the movie version is
that he does something very very daring
both as a writer and as a director in
telling this story as in the early
stages of the story the earliest years
of the story around the turn of the
century the storytelling is very is
quite realistic and naturalistic as the
story moved forward in time and to what
he felt was a much more chaotic present
he staged it in a much more surrealistic
fashion as that as the show progressed
and so it you ended up in a very
different place from where you had begun
in which of course was his whole point
about how Britain had changed over the
three decades of his lifetime and that
so many people in his audience at seen
and so this is how he staged the world
war one sequence on stage he just had
two ramps going in either direction and
these endless lines of troops marching
up and across the ramps crisscrossing
and in the fourth stage were these three
young beautiful musical comedy of
singers who were doing singing patriotic
songs of the day and there was an
electrical sign that would tell people
what year they were in and so it starts
off 1914 and the troops are marching
marching marching and the songs are very
upbeat and patriotic and happy and then
as people saw the years changed in 1915
in 1916 and 1917 the marching becomes
slower and more dirge like the music
gets distorted and twisted he even
devised a special lighting effect with
his lighting designer that the beautiful
young women on the fourth stage would
appear to age before your eyes with the
lighting effect that was world war one
you would not see stagecraft like that
in London for another 30 years and even
then it would be considered avant-garde
and here's coward doing this in 1931 in
a very mainstream entertainment the film
became a spectacular success in fact it
was the highest-grossing film of its
year the coward has left a record behind
of the making of cavalcade that's
incredibly jaundiced as his view often
was of Hollywood I'm very negative he
basically felt he felt cavalcade was one
of the few of his plays that had ever
been adapted with anything like dignity
and responsibility to the original